For some 400 years across the European Middle
Ages, one philosophy book was prized above
any other. Present in every educated person’s
library, it was titled in Latin De Consolatione
Philosophiae or, as we know it in English
today, The Consolation of Philosophy. Editions
appeared in all the large European languages,
Chaucer translated it into English, as did
Sir Thomas More and Elizabeth I – and Dante
made it a centerpiece of the intellectual
scaffolding of his Divine Comedy. The book
was the work of the Italian statesman, scholar
and academic Boethius, who penned it in a
few months in appalling circumstances in a
prison in Pavia in 523 A.D. Boethius was born
into a highly successful and wealthy family
in the years after the collapse of the Roman
Empire in the West. From an early age, he
took an interest in the Classics, and translated
much of Plato and Aristotle’s work from
Latin into Greek; it is thanks in great measure
to his efforts that Classical philosophy made
its way into the Middle Ages and from there
into the modern world. For many years, Boethius’s
life was seemingly blessed. He lived in a
sumptuous villa in Rome and was married to
a kind and beautiful woman called Rusticiana,
with whom he had two handsome, clever and
affectionate sons. Under a sense of obligation
to his society, Boethius eventually entered
politics and occupied a number of elevated
administrative positions under the ruler of
Italy, Theodoric, king of the Ostrogoths.
Bertrand Russell wrote of him: He would have
been remarkable in any age, in the age in
which he lived, he is utterly amazing. But
suddenly, in the spring of 523 A.D, Boethius’s
fortune ran out. There was a knock at the
door and a gang of Theodoric’s guards accused
him (quite falsely) of having plotted against
the increasingly paranoid and vengeful king.
With scarcely time to say goodbye to his family,
Boethius was carted off to prison. Entirely
innocent but also aware of the risk he was
in, Boethius fell into despair. In a tiny
cell, he contemplated his rapid fall from
grace, his love for his family and the unfairness
of his destiny. What would eventually lift
his spirits – and at the same time, gift
humanity one of its greatest works of prison
literature of any time or place – was his
decision to think his way philosophically
out of his sorrows. As The Consolation of
Philosophy opens, Boethius describes his listless
sadness and terror at his state: ‘White
hairs are scattered untimely on my head, and
the skin hangs loosely from my worn-out limbs’.
But in this downcast state, Boethius receives
an unexpected visit: ‘While I was pondering
thus in silence, and using my pen to set down
so tearful a complaint, there appeared standing
over my head a woman’s form, whose countenance
was full of majesty, whose eyes shone as with
fire and whose power of insight surpassed
that of all men…’ His visitor is a metaphorical
figure whom Boethius terms Lady Philosophy.
Lady Philosophy is carrying a pile of classical
books in one hand and a sceptre in the other
– and she has come to visit Boethius in
his cell in order to remind him of some of
the fundamental truths of his favourite subject,
largely as defined by the Stoic school of
Greece and Rome. That she should have dropped
in on him was, in a sense, no surprise: in
the classical world, philosophy was not an
abstract academic discipline, it was a set
of tools specifically designed to help one
live and die well, and with acute relevance
at the darkest moments. Lady Philosophy begins
by gently chiding Boethius for ‘flaring
up against’ his fate. She reminds him, as
Stoic philosophers had constantly stressed,
that human beings are not in control of most
of what happens to them. Our destiny is in
large measure in the hands of a devilishly
powerful seductive goddess whom the Romans
knew as Fortuna, the Goddess of Fortune. This
figure was a central deity in the Roman pantheon
and was represented across the Roman world
on coins and statues. She was typically depicted
holding a cornucopia in one hand, overflowing
with fruit and luxuries, and on the other,
leaning on a tiller, a marker of her capacity
to direct people’s fates. Depending on her
mood, Fortune might either shower us with
gifts or, with a blithe smile, steer us towards
catastrophe. To be a philosopher means to
understand all that Fortune controls, to resist
her blandishments, to know never to put complete
faith in the things that are, ultimately,
always in the hands of an immoral and reckless
force – and to prepare for the day when
we may have to surrender her gifts at a stroke.
These gifts comprise most of what we would
today think of as the fundamental ingredients
of happiness: love, family, children, prosperity,
reputation and career. But, for a Stoic philosopher,
none of them should be things that the wise
should ever really trust – for all of them
can be lost in horrific circumstances at any
moment. Lady Philosophy sits with Boethius
in his cell and reminds him of his appalling
exposure to Fortune’s deceptive charm: ‘I
know the many disguises of that monster, Fortune,
and the extent to which she seduces with friendship
the very people she is striving to cheat,
until she overwhelms them with unbearable
grief at the suddenness of her desertion.’
But Lady Philosophy also reminds Boethius
that the wise have to resist putting their
faith in the gifts of Fortune. She introduces
a famous image of a Wheel of Fortune, which
spins between success and favour – and appalling
punishment and pain. Fortune spins the wheel
with abandon and merciless cruelty, enjoying
the screams of those who, only hours before,
were confident of their future. ‘If you
are trying to stop her wheel from turning,
you of all men are the most obtuse,’ Lady
Philosophy tells Boethius, ‘You are seeking
to regain what really did not belong to you.’
Fortune herself pipes up at this point and
says with chilling candour: ‘Inconstancy
is my very essence; it is the game I never
cease to play as I turn my wheel in its ever
changing circle… yes, rise up on my wheel
if you like, but don’t count it an injury
when by the same token you begin to fall,
as the rules of the game will require….
Isn’t this what tragedy commemorates with
its tears and tumult?’ Lady Philosophy now
gets to the heart of her message. Boethius
must, like any good philosophically inclined
person, stop trusting in anything that Fortune
can take away at once: ‘You know there is
no constancy in human affairs, when a single
swift hour can often bring a man to nothing.’
‘If you are in possession of yourself you
will possess something you would never wish
to lose and something Fortune could never
take away…. Happiness cannot consist in
things governed by chance.’ Boethius must
retreat to what the Stoic philosophers called
his ‘inner citadel,’ a minimal self immune
from the cruelty of Fortune. Lady Philosophy
stresses that a different sort of happiness
can be found by focusing on all that Fortune
can never make one lose, specifically one’s
powers of reasoning, which give one access
to the beauty, mystery and complexity of the
universe. True philosophers rise above their
immediate circumstances, become indifferent
to their own fate and identify with the vast
forces of history and nature. It’s a measure
of the relevance of Boethius’s message that
we today so firmly identify happiness with
two areas that lie entirely in the hands of
Fortune: romantic love and career success.
And, unsurprisingly, we are continually let
down here too, the wheel of fortune spinning
us randomly from promise to disgrace, from
hope to ruin. Boethius’s provocative message
to his own times and to our own is that the
best way to find peace of mind may be to perceive
the ingredients we associate with happiness
as in truth direct conduits to a fundamental
instability, and thereby to inner torment
and anxiety. Boethius’s wisdom was to be
the last eloquent outcry of the guiding ideas
of Classical philosophy and in particular,
its Stoic branch. Thereafter, Christianity
subsumed its insights, which were then further
obscured by the scientific optimism of the
modern period. Our own troubled times deserve
to witness the rediscovery of the Stoic message.
We become philosophers not by writing books
or attending university courses, but by appreciating
how little of our lives is in our hands, the
ubiquity and fickleness of Fortune and our
need to look beyond public opinion, family,
love and status – in order to build up serenity
through the exercise of one’s distinctive
and fate-independent mental powers. Boethius
was killed, as he feared, a few months after
being imprisoned. His grave lies in the Church
of San Pietro in Ciel d’Oro in Pavia, half
an hour from Milan. In his honour, we should
leave space for Lady Philosophy occasionally
to come and visit us – and, when we are
facing the worst turns of Fortune’s wheel,
let her strengthen our resolve to depend a
little less on what was in fact never really
ours to rely upon. If you liked this film,
you might be interested in our range of books
on topics such as Relationships, Sex, Self-Knowledge
and Confidence. Click the link on your screen
now.